I'm I'm a big believer in being a
genuine really immersing yourself in
that space um so that after few years or
so and building building building that
Network providing a good service the
work's already done for you because
you've you've built those relationships
over time you've provided that good
service and people are coming back to
you with referrals and recommendations
so welcome back to another episode of
the recruitment mentors podcast I'm your
host hea Maus and on this week's episode
I was joined by Matthew Jones from
exceed so you've always been a perm
recruiter yeah other than I think the
first two months of my career where I
was put onto Salesforce recruitment in
France on a contract basis and he's
always been in the data space and for
the last two years he's been in a
hands-off role where he now has four
direct reports and he's managing 29
people across these teams he's been part
of a business that went through a
significant business event he's now
getting direct access to amazing
commercial opportunities like reporting
directly to the CEO and coo on how the
business is performing you name it we
talk about it in this conversation where
Matt really breaks down how he's got to
where he's got to why has he been able
to always continuously progress his
career in an upward trajectory and then
like you said just just be curious so
like the weekly things you do now what
what do you report on a weekly basis um
so yeah starting point will be let's get
into this week's episode Matt welcome to
the podcast thank you very much for
having me no really looking forward to
this I always love sitting down with
people that have been in the industry
for you know you've been in the industry
for a decade just done yeah and you've
you've built you know an amazing career
at ex Seed where you've been there for
eight and a half years so I'm always
interested to speak to people about you
know how that Journey's been um how
you've continued to evolve improve
because you know I think particularly in
today's day and age staying at one
company for nearly you know nine years
yeah becoming less and less common
massively we're quite lucky you see we
got quite good tenure um so I'm part of
the furniture but not the whole set
that's that's some good tenure though so
let let's give everyone some immediate
context so we're just saying done about
10 years in recruitment we're going to
focus on this this journey that you've
been on with exceed so you've always
been a perm recruiter yeah other than I
think the first two months of my career
where I was put onto Salesforce
recruitment in France on a contract
basis and yeah very quickly smooth M and
your world for a long time although this
isn't the only type of like Market that
you're involved in now is has been like
data science has been like your your
trade yeah so let's just break this down
mate we've got the the career highlight
real mate going going through here right
so from so you obviously started as an
individual contributor uh exceed so
2015 yeah 95k 2016 199k 2017 180k 2018
which was your best year 385 whilst
managing three or four people then 2019
the 320 2020 230
2021 228 up until August but in August
2021 was your last deal because um for
the last two years you've been you know
contining to evolve yourself um in this
like non- billing role yeah a lot more
of a strategic role so now you are the
head of um basically the head of UK perm
yeah so you basically manage again let
me know if I get anything wrong so you
have four direct reports they're all
like associate directors yep they report
to you got four different disciplines
data Cloud software product and then
there's 29 recruiters around about uh in
these teams y so that that is the
division that you're responsible for yep
and you uh report like directly upwards
into the like the SE Suite yeah uh and
then 2022 so then now we get talking
about net fee income which is obviously
going to be a ter that you you would
have been a lot more familiar with in
the last couple of years 2022 uh NFI for
like your like ecosystem 4 million and
then this year should be around 2.5 yeah
yeah uh we'll probably about finish on
about three I reckon year so half um
cool so a lot a lot to unpack I think
good summary yeah I'm really really
interested to talk to you about this
journey that you've been on on like
being a biller to then like having to
report directly to the CEO coo talking
about the growth looking at ebit Dar and
and profit and these things so let's
start with the million pound
question what what do you believe are
the common characteristics and traits
that make up a a top performing recruit
in today's market yeah good question as
you said I'm going to have a lot of bias
towards P recruitment um because that's
where I've spent 99% in my career um and
I think in perm as well as contract but
perm even more so I'm I'm a big believer
in being a genuine um so really
understanding the market that you
recruit in and that's not just
understanding the Technologies watching
loads of YouTube videos about what
you're actually going and recru in that
that obviously helps but really
immersing yourself in that space um so
that after few years or so and building
building building that Network providing
a good service um really understanding
the community that you're recruiting in
the work's already done for you because
you've you've built those relationships
over time you've provided that good
service and people are coming back to
you with referrals and recommendations
so I think that that helps stand out in
the crowds um you you can showcase that
in terms of events and webinars and
podcasts ultimately it's a people
business we're speaking to candidates
we're speaking to clients day in day out
and the more you can understand what
this person does on a day-to-day in
terms of their their job and what
they're doing or from the client side
what they're actually looking for that
just increases your credibility and
increases your your personal brand so
that that for me is the main one um
there's all the the normal stuff about
how hard people are working and the
organizational skills behind it um I
think what what is probably forgotten
about is this is a service Le industry
um maybe not to the extreme of the
client is always right and putting them
on a pedestal but definitely providing
that good service so always have a soft
spot for hiring people internally for
our teams that have have worked in
catering or worked in a bar or
Hospitality of some sort or sales would
be great because they get that um so
yeah I think the the part for me that's
that's how I carved out my career that's
where I see a lot of our top billers
have have genuinely built their brand
within it understand the space and are
passionate about the space um but those
other bits around organization how hard
people are working is obviously
important as
well curious just to as you I I really
um I I really agree on the piece it's
something that yeah I've continued to
really deal with my like really lean
into the last you know three four years
on the recruitment
side with that being so important to you
how like always curious to hear people's
take on like when you're hiring someone
how long do you say it takes to become a
true yeah how long's a piece of string
um realistic time I think two to three
years if we're talking about cashing in
on being an and utilizing that Network
um yeah I think I think from my
experience and people that I've seen two
to three years is a good time where you
start to see the the fruits of the labor
that you've put in for those few years
but it doesn't take long to get those
you if you if you speak to one candidate
and you can come across passionate and
interested and knowledgeable about what
they're talking about that one person
the very first person you speak to could
well go and give you the recommendation
or referral you're looking for um so
yeah I think you could get too bogged
down in being anme and researching and
getting stuck into all sorts of uh
reading and wikipedias and YouTubes
about what you do if you do that on the
side and you want to go and further
yourself into your Market fantastic um
but yeah I think to really see the
rewards of it it's a good 2 three years
no I think it's just important for
people to hear that yeah because it is
it probably takes longer than people
yeah I'm sure I mean we've seen a lot of
people that go put onto a desk maybe
maybe had a limited knowledge about it
beforehand and then try and spend weeks
and months trying to really read and
research about it and not getting the
fruits back from it necessarily straight
away um but it yeah being an SM has its
plus points in different time frames as
well you can get the plus points
straight away because you can see as I
said earlier you can you can see the
benefit of speaking to someone and
understanding that space and what that
comes back to but what I'm also
emphasizing is that being an is really
understanding the network the the market
that you're recruiting in and not just
about the skill set and that's a longer
one that that takes a good couple of
years so you saying okay that's really
interesting so you're saying I really
like the way that you how You' broken
down the time so in the short term if
I'm listening to this right now I'm in
my first year Recruitment and I I really
buy into the fact that I should be
perceived as an SM in my in my Niche the
shortterm benefits should be that I can
understand a lot more of the
conversations I'm having dayto day which
can mean you know I can ask better
questions or I can come across you know
more knowledgeable but then you're
saying the the longert benefits are if I
speak to a data scientist not only can I
understand what a typical day looks like
for Matt the data scientist I can also
go when Matt says oh I've been running
into this problem at the moment um and
yeah there's not many other people in my
team that uh have that experience you
can then go Matt I know this other
person that has been in your shoes and
they're a couple years ahead let me
connect you with them definitely that
it's definitely the connecting dots but
I think that the million dollar question
whether it's a candidate or a client
that we get every day is what's the
market like and if you're newer to it
and you're not anme and you're in first
year of recruitment even it's really
hard to know because you don't have as
much information or you don't have as
much data to go on to effectively answer
that question so you probably waffle
your way through it but if someone says
to you I'm on X salary do you think
that's a fair reflection unless you've
spoken to enough people and you
understand what the market looks like
it's really hard to give a really
detailed answer to that um but yeah
you're right I think the first part is
being an and understanding what a
candidate does what a client is looking
for in that job spec and ultim being
more effective in your job if you
understand the skill set you're more
likely to hone in and only speak to a
few people instead of having to speak to
a long short list to go through and then
whittling it down and actually not
finding the right person anyway so the
deeper the deeper you can go the earlier
the better because you're going to be
more effective at actually doing the job
and placing people but in terms of
seeing the longer fruits fruits of it
and the hard work that you've done that
does take a couple of years yeah so just
to paint a picture then on like your
role now in terms of what you I know you
said it changes a lot yeah so again you
know correct me if any of this isn't
right but some of like the the core
pillars that will uh often uh find uh
that would often find in your diary so
you have on Mondays you normally always
have your one-on ones with your ads y um
two to three days of the week you might
find yourself with key clients or
speaking to potential key customers but
involved on the the the client side M
coaching across all levels so really
getting your hands dirty on just helping
the people in this division mhm um
internal head hunting so actually
working then on you know growing the
division by uh attracting great people
uh working with with marketing maybe
around like events different things you
have going on and then you've then got
strategic object objectives that you're
involved in you might be influencing or
have ideas around maybe the the
company's BD strategy for your Division
and then you're also then like fully
exposed to all of the commercial side
the net fee income the cash flow new
business value and this is something
that you then have to report to the COO
in terms of how you're tracking against
budget EIT di here now and how often do
you do that uh well weekly at the moment
weekly yeah yeah is that fair that's a
fair it's a lot it's a big job sck um
yeah I think I think the other the other
bit that's not on there that's really
hard to to Define is anything that's
quite reactionary um and that that was
the biggest struggle for me going from a
I suppose a an individual contributor
and even my role as a bilding manager um
to them being hands off and just having
to prioritize and make sure as you said
there that's a long list of stuff to go
through so it's taken me a while to to
get to grasp of where I should spend my
time how I should divide up my weekly
monthly daily calendar um but there's a
huge portion of my time that could and
is still at the moment quite reactionary
to I don't know can you review these
terms for me or um take aside the
coaching bit because I think that that
is part of the job that happens on a
day-to-day basis but getting pulled into
to a meeting that was something that was
completely unexpected whether it's um I
don't know something around invoicing or
something that's not happened that that
that is a big chunk of my time and you
I'm learning how to deal with that
better so I'm not so reactionary I can
take a step back and be a bit more
strategic and and prioritize the jobs I
think are going to benefit business
exactly yeah okay so let let's just dive
straight in here I think I want to uh
focus on just this Evolution that you've
been on in terms of like being a leader
being a commercial leader you know
having these important like the fact
that I said to you didn't I that you
know weekly reporting to the CEO on p&l
what's Happening all that like that's
that's great exposure and like there'll
be so many lessons and and learnings
that you're you're taking uh from that
so first thing that I'm really curious
to get your take on what does effective
management managing down look like so
you got four direct reports and I'm sure
you get the stuff that they're saying so
and so is this MH so and so could be
doing better at that and you can't you
might you might have like individual
moments on like the coaching but really
for you to in order for you to be
effective yeah in your seat you have to
have those effective lines of
communication for ads to then you know
pass on any like yeah so talk to us a
bit about that like what did you firstly
what did you find Difficult about that
because that that is quite an
interesting skill set or something to
get better at what what do you find
Difficult about that to start with yeah
my first role managing managers was
actually before this role that I'm doing
at the moment so I did have a little bit
of exposure to it and managing one
manager was ahead of a lot easier than
those as those reports got bigger and
bigger um I think a lot well suppos a
lot of it's down to accountability so if
someone says they're going to do
something whether it's the consultant to
their manager or manager to me and and
back down as well right we're all held
accountable to each other and we say
we're going to do what we we said sorry
we do what we said we were going to do
um a lot of it's around fact finding so
this person's really struggling with BD
what does that mean what are they
actually doing what is that what is
their structure what is their plan are
they doing this between this particular
time talk me through it how have they
actually gone through it so I think if I
can treat the have the conversations
that I would do with a consultant the
same way that I would with an ad
everyone's got the same goal everyone
wants to to to achieve so if I can have
those same conversations it allows them
to know what sort of conversation I
would be having and have the same ones
back but then a lot of it is around the
goals and like I said so the fact
finding of what is actually going on if
someone's struggling or if someone's
doing really well and we want to
replicate that elsewhere do do the fact
finding understand what we're looking
for but then set really clear metrics
and goals behind that so yeah if we take
my weekly oneto ones with the ads for
example sitting down with them going
through individuals in their team what
we're tracking pipeline everything else
so what what's the agenda Sor to B but
like what's the agenda for those cuz I
think that would be helpful so the week
one and ones of the ads what does the
agenda look like yeah so we'll start
with last week so a review of the week
before um we used oneup um so yeah
that's the starting point it's right in
front of me um you go through the
individuals in the team how did they get
on what was the struggles what was good
what we meet terms of clients and who
we're meeting this week what's the
pipeline look like and then what
individual coaching tasks do we need to
do per person this week um so that's
that's a rough agenda to go through it
okay um and by having those
conversations on a Monday with the ads
they then have a very similar one on
their oneto ones with every consultant
within it um I took a long time to get
to
though why would do they look like
before just just a mess honestly just
like talking about whatever seems
important at the time this is going
really well but actually not thinking
about the future and what's coming in
behind it or a this person's really
really struggling with x y and Zed um so
it took me a long time to I guess just
set a structure that I was comfortable
with that I could then hold the ads
accountable to and now that now that
they know that they can do a similar
thing and replicate it for their teams
as well um I know I'm sure we'll come on
to it but we went through we went
through a merger a few years ago so
there was there was so many moving Parts
in the business combined with me growing
into this role that we we've taken a
while to get to this point that everyone
knows what the format is what sort of
conversation we're going to be having
and they have exactly the same with the
level below curious
how how do you actually walk away from
those
meetings uh and there felt like helpful
for the ad so what I mean by that is how
do you ensure that I don't I'm an I'm an
ad in your team we sit down Monday and
it's just m grilling me on numbers and
like where they should be where they're
not how do you like help like do you
know what I mean how have you approach
that cuz I think that's often you know
when we work with people Hector on
delivering training with us a lot of the
time it is like people in those seats
and a lot of the time they haven't had
much support if any on how to be a
better Coach but to be a manager so like
you can help me fact find where the
problems are but then I might not have
the skill set to go hey Matt you know
we've been running into this problem a
lot of the time like let let's talk
through that and I can effectively coach
you to hopefully get a different outcome
yeah because I feel like that's often
missed as well because if I just go into
those meetings and you're like we're all
in the red what's going on and it's all
about the numbers that I'm probably not
going to walk away from that and just
not find that helpful 100% and and and
for people who are all in the green
doesn't mean things are going perfect as
well right it's not all about yeah that
that green Amber and red traffic like
system um yeah you're right and I I
don't always have the answer so I think
that fact finding exercise is very
two-way um there's lots of tips and
advice I'm sure I can I can share with
people but it might be cool we've
identified what we think might be a
problem for this particular consultant
to go and work on let's bring in the
expertise we've got a really
collaborative space so let's bring in
the expertise from who we think is a
good person so talk about BD we've done
that as an example already so um yeah
this person's really struggling to get
conversations with hireing managers that
seems like they've got all their all
their network but they're just really
struggling to convert it into an actual
conversation who's a really good person
go through some coaching exercises or
coach out of the ads and what they can
do with that consultant but then try and
find the expertise in the business who
is really good at converting those leads
into into something and go and get them
spend half an hour 45 minutes make sure
both sides are prepped on it because it
can be quite intimidating of get this
person who's quite junior or struggling
to go and sit with a a principal or a
director or one of the top bilders but
if you if you give context on why that
meeting's taking place is that you're
obviously struggling with a at the
moment this person's fantastic at it
let's get you in a room and see how they
do it and what you can learn from it as
well I really like that I think that's
often missed a lot of comies I speak
with don't leverage that internal
expertise they just rely on people
having the courage to ask for help yeah
and people often times don't don't have
that or like don't find the right moment
or even though you can say until you
blew in the face like open door policy
reach out when you can it still rely on
that person to have the courage to ask
for help yeah and that's I suppose
that's a beauty of my role is it allows
me to have a slightly higher level view
on the strengths and weaknesses are
where we are at any point in time so it
could be in those Monday sessions that
associate director one is finding a
struggle with consultant one associate
director 2 is also finding a very
similar struggle with one of their
Consultants let's do a little workshop
let's get a few people together it can
be the broader per function in my case
um because let make it less intimidating
and less feel like
a a boot camp for those that are
struggling but let's just treat it as a
little workshop and get everyone in
together yeah no I think I I really like
that um
curious then just to talk you about
being in the seat that you're just
talking about in terms of you get like a
really unique
perspective we've spoken about BD but
I'd love to just hear your take and your
experiences of this year obviously you
guys do a lot of business in Tech right
a lot yeah so for most people I've
spoken to it's been a real challenging
year particularly more like the the
first half of the year yeah so being in
you know the seat that you're written
and what like it' be probably useful
just to hear like what have you found to
be the common challenges that you've
seen teams people run into this year
what is it what's ended up being a real
common stumbling block yeah I think
you're right it's been it's definitely
been a tougher year for us this year um
I think where where we were semi luuy
and we've also coming on to a question
about what have we done differently
because we focus on a skill set and and
a sector sorry a skill set and a yeah I
guess a niche or job title rather than
an industry you know we're not an FS
company FS recruitment agency we're not
a just a purely Tech recruitment agency
our our Client List has always been
quite diverse okay um whether that be
the age and the size of the business
right through to the actual industry and
sector so we we actually noticed well
the leadership team noticed probably
August September there was starting to
be a drop off globally um because you
know we've got some other offices
elsewhere and the US was starting to see
a dip before the UK so the the warning
signs were there quite early so we we we
got together very early on and said how
how can we combat this if the market
does start to really tighten and um and
step number one for us was identifying
Industries or client base that we
thought we could really maximize um so
there's some I guess a bit of Common
Sense around what industries we think
would be semi- Recession Proof or which
ones could do quite well out of this um
but then the second part was who have we
got really good penetration with at the
moment or or even who do we not but we
can expand on so we've we've had loads
of something we haven't really done for
a while again quite obvious but loads of
weekly client strategy sessions iny as a
leadership team to to to work out
exactly that step number one who do we
not work with or what industries do we
not work with at the moment that we want
to and step number two how do we wrap
our arms around those that we think
could still see us through this um and
it's it's 100% paid dividend it's it's
been a slightly different way of working
to be honest with you what's paid
dividend sorry the weekly client
strategy like just having an intentional
space each week to talk about those two
things exactly that yeah yeah and again
holding each other accountable if
someone says say you know ABC limited I
want to really expand on them cool let's
Identify some higher managers within ABC
limited let's put a little task force
together to go and introduce ourselves
map it out as an organization and then
let's report back next week on where
we're up to with each of that you know a
week and recruitment is nothing it'll
completely fly by but at least we're
then tracking it on a weekly basis on
where we're getting up to with that
client um but it's it's as I said very
different way of working for us you know
traditionally we've because we've been
focused on a skill job title
historically we would work AG consultant
maybe 30 40 vacancies any one time and
it was much more tailored to the
candidate so you can speak to a
candidate and whatever they were
interested on looking for we we
generally have a role on our roster that
could be suitable for them um and then
all of a sudden the job vacancies were
dropping and dropping and dropping and
we've now had to be much more client
driven you know just the traditional
going from a candidate driven Market to
a job driven Market but I think
appreciating that and not just saying oh
it'll be fine we'll just stick to our
way of working implementing these client
strategy sessions were 100% a game
changer for us and are you are you doing
those with individuals or your ads it's
not it's not necessary to says it's
whoever we think has got you know we'll
pull people in so if there's a client
that one of the junior Consultants is
working with but they've got a good
relationship with them cool let's bring
them in so it's not just the leadership
team or management team it's us that set
it up and and is up and running with it
but it's any anyone who we think is
relevant for it I love that honestly you
be
so so many people don't like make space
for stuff like that it's just that all
they're making sure people are doing is
doing the eight hours of BD a week
yeah BD is it's never ending task right
and you say go and do BD most people
will go and sit on the advert see what
adverts are out there put a couple of
specs together and fire it out BD can
just be so much more interesting and so
much more exciting if you actually put a
little task force and strategy behind it
um understand how and why yeah yeah yeah
definitely and also buddying people up
right that example I mentioned earlier
of someone who might be a more Junior
consultant perhaps that's a great
exposure for them to maybe work with a
couple of other more senior people whove
been doing it a lot longer but buying up
and actually getting a little task force
together to go and tackle that client
this podcast is proudly partnered with
vin Cherry the all-in-one recruitment
agency software that over 20,000
recruiters trust daily we're also
partnered with the award-winning oneup
sales sales and mtiv ation platform that
enables you to maximize the potential of
your teams we love partnering with both
of these organizations because they
share our mission and helping you get
the most out of your people and your
business you can get exclusive offers
because you listen to this podcast and
get up to 10% of the usage price forever
use a link in the show notes to get your
hands on that let's get back to the
episode okay let's just talk about this
for a sec just because one to clear
that's being
impactful and people people listening
that this could be something that they
could sort of consider implementing in
in their teams
M so you said with the client Strat so
like basically saw signs early on so
then then basically you made the
decision that each week you're going to
make intentional time to talk about yeah
what are we doing specifically on the
client side that we feel is going to be
you know a smart choice with our time
and you know equip people with like a
plan um and like you said hold each
other accountable so just talk just talk
to me about firstly how how long are
these how long are these sessions
typically about an hour now they were
long to start with cuz step number one
was the the mapping out of who we want
to even go to um so that that was quite
longwinded I think one one of the key
things we learned over time was the
shorter the list the better um you don't
want hundreds of companies on this
because it's just going to be this
NeverEnding task that actually defeats
the purpose of what it's meant to be
which is really t a really specific um a
list that we think is going to maximize
opportunity for us um um so that was I
think we got down to 10 10 per sections
the 10 that we don't work with that we
want to and 10 that we do work with that
we want to continue and expand okay so
so basically the F the first step was
who are they who yeah who who are we
going after and you break it down into
two categories yeah who do we don't who
do we not work with that we want to and
who do we currently work with or have
terms with that we feel like we could be
doing way more with yeah on the first
category what ended up being like how
what ended up being like the key bits in
terms of what why did they make it into
that category yeah it's mainly size and
space um so Pi energy for example see
was doing doing all right so so energy
clients were a big one for us and we W
going specifics but we broke into a
couple off the back of that task Alone
um looking for ones that
were the sexier Brands the VCS were
probably the ones to avoid for us you
know in a tighter Market VC Le
businesses were less likely to go and do
huge rounds of um of recruitment so I
think swerving those which were
traditionally a huge client base for us
that that was our sweet spot is series a
through to IPO type businesses and
helping them scale um so actually
swerving them as much as possible and
probably more the traditional household
Brands the Foie 100 organizations um but
again spreading our bets a little bit so
looking at Telco energy oil and gas and
and really spreading in it that way so
did you have people come to those
sessions with hey Mt these are the
clients that I think on to put in this
category everyone yeah everyone so
everyone came like the task was right
guys I wanted to identify clients that
yeah you don't work if you want to that
you might that you got terms with that
you're not doing as much with and then
they come to that session and then you'd
break it all down together on like if
they should stay in that category or not
exactly that yeah I think so going back
to your question of um why them as well
one thing forgot to mention is obviously
they have a team or have a need for the
skill set re recruit yeah sure um so
yeah looking at ones they have a problem
that you feel like they can tell for
them yes maybe not even necessary
problem yet CU we don't know um but at
least that they've got some sort of
function there or or we think there is a
good use case for a function there with
your skill sets exactly yeah okay so
that took a couple of weeks to get it
whittled down to a core list of
companies that was manageable for people
to take consistent action on over a week
yeah okay that's the first step which I
think one for anyone listening if if
your Consultants can't tell you at least
10 that go in both those categories or
maybe just the first category because I
haven't got any terms signed missing a
trick or making it more hard for them
cuz then you're making it very clear
just giving them really clear companies
and Brands to be going after rather than
just yeah I think that just helps you
know having a clear Direction so we've
done that and then what what did the
sessions then consist of so if I'm
coming to that session you're like okay
look these these companies look great
heam yeah definitely and these companies
over here as well perfect that's a
really good list what we then focusing
on yeah get again it took a few weeks to
get the format um but what what where
we've kind of landed up to is then
putting task force per consult per
client sorry what would the task force
mean um so teams are three or four um so
yeah let's call them ABC limited um so
trying to make sure there is someone the
four skill sets we recruit in terms of
data software cloud and product making
sure there is one person from each of
those sub teams from exceeds who's going
to go and try and map out their space
within that client right um so it
doesn't always need to be the leadership
doesn't always need to be a principal
consultant as I said really trying to
get other people bought into what we're
doing just a different way of thinking
um so making sure there is a task force
with said three or four people um per
client and then what what sort of um
metrics or information do we want to
come back with next week so it's a bit
easier for the ones that we've already
got the terms with or we've already
worked with and placed with that is much
more around I guess drawing a little we
drew up um a nice grid of how where have
we transacted in internally with each of
those clients so if we've already
transacted in data products software and
Cloud Wicked they're a gold client for
us how do we get even more out of them
and that might be leveraging on
um those relationships with ta and HR to
maximize that a bit further sell in
different solutions to see if we can get
some retained or exclusive work within
there um but then the easiest one
actually is looking through that grid
and seeing where the gaps are so we
might have transacted with them in data
but we've never transacted with with
them in the other skill sets let's make
sure we're getting those introductions
into those CTO CPO VPS whatever the job
titles be um and then break it down that
way the the ones of who we we haven't
yet worked with that's a bit harder
because where' you start um by having
the task force because we've been so
skill setled that's that's a good
starting point so you have one person
from data they'll reach out to the data
managers and say hey this is who we are
this is what we've done with the
competitors and go through that way
what's been I think that's what people
be interested in like what's what's
worked well yeah what what's I know it
varies like has it been specking has it
been talking about the events that you
run I know it might vary per skill set
but what what have you found to be the
most consistent thing that people would
come back into that client session we
were going hey had really good week this
week did this did that and we managed to
get a first meeting yeah I think I think
for this task not the specking um we we
see good success from specking into into
live leads and there's a very specific
problem here's a very specific solution
that that makes sense this was this is a
bit more proactive right this is I don't
know if you're hiring at the moment if
you have any plans to but but if you are
this is why I could be a good partner
for you so it's much softer and and what
we've seen like bucket number two of
clients we already work with that's a
bit easier to to quantify quickly
because it's okay we we've not yet
transacted in this area can we come back
and say that a meeting is booked in this
time next week so that's a bit easier to
do what's worked with us or what we've
started to see work for us in bucket
number one of clients we don't work with
is that longer term relationship
building you know we're now probably
seven or eight months properly into this
task force of How It's all working and
and those conversations those clients
that we're bringing on board those jobs
we're now put pull in have taken a long
time to get to there so again anyone
listening it's a patience with it I know
it's the most frustrating thing to hear
um but yeah we haven't had a golden
bullet as you said it's been our events
it's been our podcasts it's been our
webinars um a lot of it's just been
showcasing work that we've done in their
specific area so whether it's a
competitor we've placed with or
companies that are in and around their
world how showcase out there like Cas
studies packs yeah PDF packs um not so
much one Pages cuz I think there's
there's quite a bit of information we
can put on there um so yeah the more
packs we can provide the better we've
got our standards um client brocher and
then we'll just add a few slides that
are specific to that client or that
sector and that industry I mean you'd be
surprised how many people don't have
that this is the thing we've only done
it off the back of this as well really
yeah yeah we we've had a client brochure
but it's been so generic it wasn't
specific you're like that's what makes
it more impactful right yeah but this
our Market team are wicked so we work
very closely with them to make sure that
we've got a every consultant has access
to the share drive so they can get their
own um what do you call it but yeah the
the amendable packs basically and then
there's the temp energy like energy
product or whatever yeah and then a lot
of it is okay if I'm new to it and I'm
going to go and Target an energy
business what energy clients have we um
have we with before and that's that's
not on a CRM you know we don't yet have
something that we can segment based on
industry and get all the testimonials
ready made so there is a bit of work
going in the background to get to that
point where it's a nice polished
brochure a nice inroduction that goes
out so that someone actually opens it
okay these guys know what they're doing
yeah and it's not yeah it's not just
what you're saying to me it's there's I
can point that exactly yeah what have
you just curi just curious and like what
what's ended up in these packs is it
just a combination of testimonials is it
we reduce their hiring time to this that
sort of stuff what um I can't remember
the Tom I had all the individual bits
but a lot of it is Introduction to ex
see the skill sets recruit high level
testimonials for us as a business
generally so some key logo Brands a page
that then specific to that industry with
logos of competitors or people that
we've placed in and around there and
then some quotes from four or five
people again the more varied in terms of
someone from product someone from data
someone from Tech the better um we've
got one page which is around the service
level offering that can provide whether
it's contingent retained um we've got
one page in there that is specific to
what we do within the community around
our events and our webinars and
everything else um and then one that's a
link to our salary guide so I think all
together it's just a nice polish this is
who exceed are and what we do but you
can tell it's tailored to them tailored
to them yeah I love that now I
appreciate you sharing that I know as as
you all know like so many people people
have struggled like I just really like
how start to see a problem come with a
solution you refined out over time and
now youve it sounds like you've got a
process that actually has ended up being
really valuable to have in your in your
teams to be doing on a weekly basis and
it's constantly improving as well right
like I think assuming that you've got to
the the end goal is the worst thing you
can do by constantly improving whether
it's the packs that we're putting
together and people have got different
ideas maybe it's moving away from a pack
all together and doing a video
introduction or something but I think
keeping fresh making sure a so it's
enjoyable so that the job itself cuz BD
can be quite a thankless task so by
having these task force it feels quite
quite interesting it's a bit more
Project based yeah I like that you I
like that it's not I I do also like that
obviously you've got the benefit of the
different skill sets and the different
divisions but I do I do like that idea
of the task force cuz then you can sort
of bounce off each other and be like oh
man I managed to get into like I spoke
to the data person how you getting on
with product person I think that's a
quite smart way to exactly talk talk to
me then about like I wanted to frame
this up in a way
where when you started to then like what
what was the beginning steps of Matt now
having to understand P now and these
things when did that start to H
happen um I couldn't even put a specific
date on it it'sit more and more so as
the months go by um I think probably
tail end of 20121 was when I was in my
non- billing role um and that was the
first time my all almost single-handedly
took responsibility for a budget um so
August August 2021 I kind of I think I
did my last deal then um in September
October time we were starting to put
together the NFI budget for the year uh
well sorry for next year um and that was
the first time it wasn't just a okay
cool what's the NFI and the nbv going to
be for a team how does that trickle down
to to eidar and um yeah it was it was a
learning curve and still is a learning
curve on the importance of it and we
talked about cash flow and invoice and
everything else that comes with it
um but I think by spending more time
with my CEO at the point in time and
also our CFO now on on the importance of
it and learning through it quite lucky
my wife is an accountant so that helps I
got a little bit of an insight to it but
yeah probably probably formally this
time two years ago give or take so what
was
you like as you started that and as you
continue learning about that executing
the reports looking at your important
dashboards what was you most surprised
by
is what I'm interested in so someone
listen to this right now they're a
recruiter they might have aspirations to
get to where you got to or become an
associate director or
whatever if yeah like with those set of
glasses on like what do you think they'd
be most surprised by is it how long it
takes typically to get paid or I don't
know like what were some of the things
you're like oh that's really interesting
how that works or I didn't expect that
yeah how long how long it takes to get
paid definitely
um I'm trying to think the other I
suppose the actual conversion rate so we
maybe specific to us as a business and
the pain points we've had over the last
few years but seeing a phenomenal month
of what I thought was NFI and what that
equates to at the end um and then also
trying to then explain that cuz we're
really transparent explain that back to
the sales floor on you it may feel like
we're absolutely killing it but we need
we still need to work on these areas and
that's why we need to a lot of it has
come from em merger so there was very
bloated costs that not just about
headcount or anything like that but
things like insurance and loads of other
bits that I've never even considered and
that ultimately trickles down to the
bottom line um so I think that that was
a biggest one maybe specific to me at my
point in time and where the company was
that the business 2021 2022 was a
phenomenal year for recruitment but
actually heit I was looking at that like
Sur we making more money than that but
it's um yeah I I think that was the
biggest maybe not a learn but I guess
just the biggest shock and then okay how
can we well you never would have had to
think about that before no no it's true
um I think the other one which is I was
already familiar with but is the the
difference in motivation between mbb and
NFI and that's obviously from a from a
per point of view contracts maybe a bit
bit more transparent because that's what
you're tracking on a weekly weekly basis
with your your Runner book um but seeing
a phenomenal month of mbv so wait let
just explain that sorry yeah so so mbv
for us is uh new business value so
whatever I I play a candidate today put
the deal through once they've ticked all
the boxes that we're happy with for
compliance that goes on that goes on the
board that's our NB
yeah um NFI is when we actually get paid
when the company gets paid so in perm um
especially in the UK let's say people
have got a 3 month notice I do a deal
today in October that candidate might
not start till January the NFI then
comes through in January get paid
commission in February so it it was a
slightly different you know we get paid
on candidate starting that's already
part of your thinking process but it's
celebrating most of the celebrations we
have in terms of our our incentives our
lunch clubs our holidays is all around
mbv um and I do think that's the right
way of doing it for us as a business
anyway is because we want to be
constantly driving new activity rather
than the same top billers sitting on
their NFI and getting on the incentives
that's not really what it's about um so
that was that was another one as well
is great nbv doesn't necessarily equal
NFI in that quarter or in that month so
trying to actually try and check it and
look at the seasonality behind it as
well because there seasonality behind
placing candidates and doing deals but
there's huge seasonality on when those
candidates are going to start the job um
start tracking for that yeah what the
biggest DEC December's a ghost town
hardly anyone start well in my case
anyway hardly anyone starts in December
so allowing for that seasonality um and
step number one for me when I did my
first ever budget which is something to
learn from was okay let's go through go
through the individuals so Joe blogs
this is what I think they're going to do
this year and I just divided it by 12
that's what an NFI would be just yeah
let's say they're 120k why do you think
divid it by 12 just just in terms of
ease of month and then uh very quickly
got pushed back to me and said have you
thought about when those nfis are
actually going to land in the
seasonality behind it okay that makes
that makes sense um so the whole way
through this has been quite a good
learning curve yeah that
CU I I do think I think I said to you I
did a a post about it this week where I
think if people to go out on their own
and start their own recruitment business
that's often one of the things that they
uh maybe like not didn't think of but
underestimate yeah so like like have you
now found yourself trying to impact how
quickly the NFI is in terms of you know
have people talk about payment terms and
negotiate those things in the process
cuz they're the types of things that you
can try and implement or communicate or
have people do more effectively that can
help with NFI yeah no definitely um I
think you said it yourself it's it's an
education piece so more I didn't have
that exposure from someone saying to me
this is why we want 30-day payment terms
or 14-day payment terms instead of 60
that the client have asked for and
that's why it's important to negotiate
at the point when you're billing 99% of
it yeah you just you just want the term
signed you want to place a candidate and
you want to move on to the next one um
so that is yeah something I I've been
aware of and then I I've always been
quite an open and transparent person and
anything I learn I want to try and in
part on those that that are interested
and obviously will will be um will be
relevant for so explaining to them you
know the Consultants who was agreeing
new terms on oh do I need to push back
on it being 50 day or 45 day payment
terms let's try let's go through it this
is what you can explain to the client
this is why why it is important for us
as a business as well um I my my my
focus is perm so I can understand having
now had some exposure to The Wider
business I I get it even more so from a
contract point of view because I think
we we talked about it um earlier in the
week about um some really big projects
that we've landed and our CFO having
kittens about it because actually we
don't get paid and sorry we we pay the
cand um the contractors up in advance
and then we're not getting the money
back until x amount of days so the cash
flow for us is so so important and
that's that's something I've never
really had to think about in my roles up
until the last couple of years and then
how how did you find those first few
reports upward were you nervous was it
what what went wrong what not really
because it wasn't an it wasn't a change
overnight it's not as though these have
been Matt's doing this role now and then
tomorrow is going to change and it's be
completely different a lot of this has
been been transition said I've been at
the business for a long time so a lot of
the people I've been reporting up to
have had the journeys as I have as well
um so it's been it's been an easier
transition than maybe some other people
experien where it is a flick of a switch
and going through it um but as I said
there's I don't know hopefully this
isn't just exceeding is the wider
recruitment industry but there's no
point in trying to catch people out um
if I'm nervous about reporting back up
then ultimately I'm probably going to
Fumble something along the way it's I'd
much rather report something up that is
inaccurate EG don't do a just a divide
by 12 for what you think the NFI is
going to be have you thought about it
this way and and that that EOS is what
we've got as a business so not really it
wasn't something I was too nervous
about and then like you said just just
be curious like the weekly things you do
now what what do you report on a weekly
basis um so yeah starting point will be
the NFI um NFI and mbb so what we do
last week where does that fall into how
does that track against the budget that
we put in place um and then there's a
similar conversation to what I have with
the ads so how less less granular so
less around individual Consultants um
but it will be how how was last week as
a as a function do we hit our kpis do we
not hit our kpis what does that mean
what's the impact what clients are we
meeting this week so most most of it's
just about a sounding board um and it's
me talking to Adam our coo and and
talking to him about the week that we've
had and him bouncing some ideas back off
we work quite well as a pair what's
been when you're getting the the direct
access to the the CEO what what's been
some of the sort of most memorable or
best bits of advice is imparted on you
do you
think good question I haven't really
thought about that I suppose most of it
is to trust my instinct or or at least
go with it because same as the people
underneath me that we we promote people
because we believe they should be um so
by stepping into this role someone some
point along the way had faith in me that
I can go and do this um now there this
is probably the biggest jump in terms of
a learning curve you know going from a
uh senior principal type person to a
manager I had the coaching stuff in me
already so that this is this is by far
the biggest jump because there a whole
new tool set that I'm having to learn um
but just I think just having the the
faith that someone out there has
believed in me to go and do this role so
them passing that back on to me that I
can go and do it um and if it's not
something I'm familiar with ask for
help and then curious cuz there's a lot
of different
things like we said at the beginning
like a lot there's a lot on that list
that you could be doing you're trying to
figure out to get better
at like being like less reactive but
maybe that's always going to be part of
your role so just C curious to hear your
take on like right now from your
perspective because you've been doing
this for a couple of years now what do
you think are some of like some of if
not the like highest leverage activities
you can spend your time on a lot client
client stuff yeah definitely um
especially at the moment where we are
job lighter sorry lighter for for jobs
than we used to um the more I can be
bringing in the more I can be on those
meetings and maximizing um that's not to
mean I am better than anyone in the
business necessarily but um I have a
fancier job title which is part of it
right so if I'm going to go and meet a a
head of ta head of HR or even some SE
sues within the business just by being
there add some credibility to the
consultant that I'm going with or the
couple of the Consultants I'm going with
um but that's the main thing you know
the more clients we can be winning or
maximizing the more jobs the more deals
we can be doing and ultimately the the
quicker we'll progress as a business so
that's one of the things that has always
got to stay should that should trickle
down in terms of having one of the
biggest impacts definitely on your on
your function yeah I love that yeah I'm
I'm not surprised to hear that I think
also like you by you going to those
meetings you're staying close
to the problems in your industry what
people are talking about you can then
also you know offer your perspective you
can you can talk about how you're seeing
this in the in the data industry that
could be impacted in the Product
Industry I don't know exactly how it
works but you've got a really great
unique perspective that you can I'm sure
you can add for sure in those things as
well speaking about um BD I think
something that you said you you proud
yourself on is thinking outside the
box yeah do tell us a story about how
you Le delivery then I hope no one from
work listens to this um why is there no
know no no is it's just they fed up
hearing
it no it's um well when I was a this is
probably two or three years into the job
um I I just got bored of doing the same
sort of BD approaches right that I think
keep them you have to do the basics you
have to do your specking you have to do
your outreaches you have to do your
intros but I I quite like just trying to
do something new so as um as cheesy as
it was with uh so this was deliveroo as
they were I think Ser series a at the
time so quite quite smaller business
than they are now and um they were
growing their first data team and I
remember seeing uh I think someone from
Netflix um incredible caliber candidate
joined them as their Chief and so I
thought that's you're not hiring someone
of that caliber if you're not going to
go and expand a team and um their office
was a 5 minute walk from ours so um
after Relentless approaches being
rejected and just turned down and just
radio silence I um think myself to get a
box of crispy creams print out a couple
of uh well had took our client brocher
with us and a couple of anonym my CVS I
think the the tagline I put on the note
was um you've been delivering to me for
the last few months I'd love to deliver
cand see you lo and behold he became a
good client for us so it did pay off but
um but like what you walked into the
reception walked into the reception
dropped him dropped him off oh you
dropped him off you didn't like trying
to speak well I did but the guy wasn't
there so what did you say like it's so
and so here can you yeah so and so here
can you uh well it wasn't so can you
leave these for him so if he was what
would you have said uh how would you
approach that probably same as what it's
on the note so yeah been ping you why
have you not answer my messages really
no um yeah a lot of it would been in the
the colder intro this is who I am know
it's really cheesy but I think just by
doing that alone would get some sort of
interaction right well and then you just
got a phone call yeah I got a message a
few weeks later so thanks for the donuts
not even like us a few weeks later as
well yeah it was it wasn't straight away
at all no kept kept me stewing but but
this is the thing with BD right unless
you get very very lucky it's it's about
timing um and I think where people
struggle is that they they give up too
early or they maybe do one or two
approaches and then nothing back from
them they got no interest and move on to
the next one but these things take a
long of time I know there's all sorts of
sales analogies about the nth approach
10th approach or whatever but it's true
100% um so I think the worst thing that
someone can do earlier in their career
is pick up a job off the first approach
because then you think that's how it how
it does yeah if you got any other maybe
doesn't have to be yours but any other
ideas that people have tried any other
ideas but has anyone done anything else
uh I try think paid off off yeah not not
cheesy ones like that a lot of our stuff
um at the moment especially is is events
L um to go and loop them back to that
subject matter of expertise but we had
we held an event this Tuesday and the
amount of clients that I've been trying
and trying and trying you get them in a
room and actually they can see that you
you host something good and there's some
good credibility behind it and then
without any prompting they come up to
you and say I know you've been speaking
to us actually now might be good time to
talk about recruitment um it's just it's
just one of those things but yeah we
we've seen really good success from
event Le things whether it's round taes
webinars um start a podcast series
actually so that that'll be coming out
soon but these in person networking
events definitely and like where where
do you often
see like the net positive of that is it
the in you know having a reason to reach
out to people is it that isn't like jobs
and the typical like stuff is it the the
followup where it's really powerful is
it just being in the room with these
people and then it feels like maybe a
bit more of a safe space to yeah and I
think credibility right I think if
people come to something and they see
the brand and they associate it with
something that's great in their space
then there's that positive recognition
there
um the only the only risk I would say
with having a reason to speak to someone
is we see it sometimes where people can
fall into the Trap of becoming event
managers and event Bookers and and
forgetting that actually why we're
speaking to these people um yes there's
the long-term relationship build but
actually it's recruitment right that's
that's the end goal of why we're trying
to do all of these things is to help
clients build their teams um and I think
if you do so many events and webinars
and round taes people can get so lost in
that that they forget the day today
um so I think your first point of do you
do these just because it's another point
to talk to people about yes if it's the
right measurement of it um but I think
the main the main thing is The
credibility you know we don't we don't
go to an we don't organize an event
expecting to Come Away with 10 jobs or
10 new clients or anything like that
that' be great but a lot of it is about
those those longer term relationships
and that brand recognition within that
community and you're you're the
perception of your credibility what
you're about increasing no you are right
it's it's just that is that I think
that's often why sometimes when I speak
to recruitment Founders they feel like
it is going to end up being just about
that and there isn't that conversion but
know it is I would I don't know if you
would agree but I would say know leaning
into that type of approach it is like a
you're definitely going to get tons of
net positive things happen in the long
term but you should definitely
experience short-term medium-term yeah
wins as well but I think it is just as
simple as making sure if you do speak to
anyone about and that's your reason why
you're reaching out to them that you
will say this is why we put these
together this is the purpose of them if
you do attend this is what to expect and
look you know before I leave you or like
why we do these it's because exceed with
this and we do that like just educating
people on this is what we're about this
is what we do this is what we're
different this is just part of you know
what we're trying to deliver for our
Network to hopefully provide even more
value um to the people that we work with
day and day out I think sometimes people
Miss like yeah like educating people on
you know this is why we do this and this
is what we do our business yeah and and
the follow-ups with it as well right CU
it's all very well having that
conversation there and then but it's
it's the Fallout meeting call whatever
it be off the back of it yeah so talk to
me about as we come to the end here then
talk to me about what like you're in a
really unique position you've you've
made some really good adjustments like
the client strategy sessions which which
I I really loved like going into next
year then like what are you remaining
laser focused on what is it that you're
really thinking like that needs to be in
your top three agendas is like what's
really top of mind going into next year
when thinking about performance and and
your function yeah it's it's been a
learning year for us so I think going
away from as I said job LED JBL JBL um I
was s candidate driven but in in a jobed
market um and now it's much more about
quality in everything that we do so um
we're we're putting together our whole s
sounds again Going Back to Basics but um
everything from the candidate experience
through to someone on boarded and post
service so what what does every single
step look like um it it times in with a
new CM roll out for us as well so
there's there's reasons behind it but
that step number one is how do we
maintain how do we M make sure that
every single touch point with exceed is
a high quality service um because that's
as I said that's that's the free BD if
you're if you're providing a good
quality service then that's exactly what
candidates and clients want to work with
um and that's what makes people
rememberable memorable and then coming
back to um so number one is moving into
this quality Le Focus um we've got our
own I know you're going to ask me what
they are I can't remember the top of my
head but we've got our own metrics that
we're measuring for um the 3 C's
candidates clients and colleagues um so
every Q La we have our quarterly
launches um we're now talking about
those three C's and four measurements
per C of what quality how how we can
track the quality so to give people an
example sorry net promot yeah um so I
think I think like on the client side
yes reviews is one bit of it but um a
good quality client for us not just a
good quality interaction with exceed to
a client what does a good quality client
look like and once upon a time we would
have said all the sexy logos and really
cool tech companies but actually a dream
client for us is one that is is
transacting in multiple multiple
locations ideally but also multiple um
skill sets with us and that is a good
quality client so tracking on a quarter
by quarter basis how many clients are
what we call a gold client that's
operating in all of those Services there
um and I think just that having that
that slight shift in mentality of okay
we talk about quality but how do we
measure that we measure it and those
three C's there and again not just our
colleague not just our clients and our
candidates but the colleagues as well
how do we make sure this is a really
quality business to work for and that
people enjoy working here and and feel
valued exciting I think the I the person
um before you Abby we spoke like she's
really passionate about that and I think
that is again something that I feel like
a modern day recruitment business is
going to have to like really lean into
um cuz as you just said the way you
described it let's be honest yeah free
BD mhm but also I think if you really
lean into delivering a like world class
experience for clients for candidates
for
colleagues it then just helps everything
yeah for right um and also what that
should feel like a fun exercise like how
can we how can we make each step amazing
um I think that's a great thing to be
focusing on and thinking about and have
that Pride with it yeah Matt it's been a
pleasure thank you I think you've been
on an awesome Journey uh I think clearly
like there's still going to be tons more
to learn like really exciting what
you're going to continue to be exposed
to how you're going to help Drive the
business forward I think this is what I
love about industry like you started as
a salesperson right you know recruiter
and now you're in the rooms with you
know people that have built successful
businesses you're involved in how you
become more profitable like this is the
great thing about industry there's so
much you can learn for sure right and
especially if you keep progressing and
you want to down go down this leadership
route like all these things you're
learning um are just just valuable
forever yeah we touched on this earli in
the week didn't we that recruitment is a
career yeah and I think there are so
many so many people that fall into
recruitment for for one of a better
phrase um but and it took me probably a
couple of years to realize this this can
be a career this isn't need to be
something that I'm just bumbling into
and not sure what I'm going to do later
on in life and yeah I've been really
lucky I've had a wicked Journey with
exceed and um I think they've opened
mind eyes to this being a career um and
I'm I'm really Keen to instill that
opportunity in others underneath me as
well it's not just okay this is wicked
for me I'll go down my own little
journey now I want to try and take
people through the education pieces that
I'm having now and everything from a
consultant understanding why payment
terms is important and that what that
all leads to so thing to do love that
Matt it's been a pleasure likewise
appreciate it thank you very much